Lucia: 釉下彩吧这个
Lucia: This is underglaze color, right?
Tasha: 釉上釉下呀
Tasha: Overglaze or underglaze, yeah.
Jake:左上左下
Jake: Upper left, lower left.
Lucia: 哈哈哈就是
Lucia: Haha, exactly.
Lucia: 两种上上彩的方式
Lucia: Two ways to apply the glaze.
Jake:是先上什么再上什么是吧
Jake: So, what goes on first?
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
Tasha: 就相当于是你先把这个白色的烧出来
Tasha: It's like you first fire the white part.
Tasha: 然后再把这个花纹涂上
Tasha: Then you paint the pattern.
Tasha: 你还是一开始就把花纹也涂上
Tasha: Or you paint the pattern first.
Tasha: 然后再烧
Tasha: And then fire it.
Lucia: 我觉得釉右上吧
Lucia: I think it's overglaze.
Lucia: 嗯不是很会
Lucia: Hmm, not really sure.
Lucia: 我只烧过一次
Lucia: I've only fired once.
Lucia: 这个东西
Lucia: This thing.
Tasha: 如果是釉右上踩的话
Tasha: If it's overglaze,
Tasha: 其实吃着就有毒
Tasha: It's actually toxic to eat off of.
Tasha: 就对身体不好
Tasha: It's bad for your health.
Tasha: 因为把这些矿物质原料吃进去
Tasha: Because you ingest these minerals.
Tasha: 如果是釉下彩的话就更健康一点
Tasha: If it's underglaze, it's healthier.
Tasha: 但是它的花纹就没那么好看
Tasha: But the patterns aren't as nice.
Tasha: 颜色也不好看
Tasha: The colors aren't as good.
Lucia: 感觉回到了我大学那个课上
Lucia: Feels like I'm back in my college class.
Lucia: 他们出来了吗
Lucia: Have they come out?
Jake:给他们一点小任务
Jake: Let's give them a little task.
Jake:哎他们找到了
Jake: Oh, they found it.
Jake:你好啊
Jake: Hello.
Nicous: 这是华为
Nicous: This is Huawei.
Jake:华为
Jake: Huawei.
Jake:你们怎么找到的
Jake: How did you find it?
Jake:就是你们
Jake: It's you guys.
Jake:你们也不知道华为在哪
Jake: You don't even know where Huawei is.
Lucia: 理论上说地球是圆的
Lucia: Theoretically, the earth is round.
Lucia: 对吧所以你只要往一个方向走
Lucia: Right? So if you walk in one direction,
Lucia: 肯定能回到原点
Lucia: You'll definitely return to the start.
Jack: 你这车有BIOS吗
Jack: Does your car have BIOS?
Jack: 哎他这个车BIOS不是很强
Jack: Hey, this car's BIOS isn't very strong.
Choiszt: 我靠能送到那个停车场
Choiszt: Damn, it can get us to that parking lot.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey.
Lucia: 这给他抓回去放门口吧
Lucia: Let's take him back and leave him at the door.
Lucia: 不是他就趴在这个帐篷里
Lucia: No, he just laid down inside the tent.
Katrina: 可乐拿一瓶
Katrina: Grab a bottle of Coke.
Tasha: 为什么他搞了辆这么新的
Tasha: Why did he get such a new one?
Jake:对啊为什么
Jake: Yeah, why?
其他人：地下停车场拿的
Others: Got it from the underground parking lot.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:讲究
Jake: Fancy.
其他人：这是随便随便拿
Others: Just grabbed it casually.
Lucia: 哎呦对不起
Lucia: Oops, sorry.
Jake:咱们刚刚讨论过
Jake: We just discussed this.
其他人：但是历史上好没拍
Others: But it's never been filmed in history.
Jake:没拍他是在真人的脑海里
Jake: It's never been filmed, it's in real people's minds.
其他人：自由发挥
Others: Freestyle.
Jake:二锅头整点
Jake: Let's have some Erguotou.
Jake:二锅头可以
Jake: Erguotou is fine.
Lucia: 真的吗
Lucia: Really?
其他人：喝吗
Others: Drink it?
Nicous: 我就是喝这个给我喝到急诊室
Nicous: I drank this and ended up in the emergency room.
其他人：喝吗
Others: Drink it?
Nicous: 喝你爸死都不会喝一口汾酒
Nicous: Drink it, your dad wouldn't even touch Fenjiu.
Jake:为什么呀
Jake: Why?
Nicous: 就是喝这个吃到急诊室
Nicous: Because he drank this and ended up in the emergency room.
Jake:什么时候喝的
Jake: When did he drink it?
Nicous: 过生日过年
Nicous: On birthdays, New Year's.
Jake:过生日
Jake: On birthdays.
Jake:就是和出生一样在医院度过的生日
Jake: Just like being born, spent his birthday in the hospital.
Jake:出生的时候一样在医院度过的
Jake: Just like when he was born, spent it in the hospital.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 今天奇怪问答的含量好高啊
Lucia: Today's strange Q&A content is so high.
Lucia: 啊没有刚才
Lucia: Ah, no, just now.
Lucia: 什么情况下
Lucia: In what situation?
Lucia: 生日在医院上哈哈
Lucia: Birthday spent in the hospital, haha.
Lucia: 哎好像那天
Lucia: Oh, seems like that day.
Lucia: 谢冰竹讲过
Lucia: Xie Bingzhu talked about it.
Lucia: 不过我有点忘记了
Lucia: But I kind of forgot.
Lucia: 你是你是又喝了牛奶还是怎么回事
Lucia: Did you drink milk again or what?
Lucia: 还有乳糖不耐受那次吗
Lucia: Was it the lactose intolerance time?
Lucia: 哦那是另一次
Lucia: Oh, that was another time.
Lucia: sorry我错了
Lucia: Sorry, my bad.
其他人：因为现在我要拿6瓶
Others: Because now I need to get 6 bottles.
其他人：喝了两瓶鸡尾酒
Others: Drank two bottles of cocktails.
其他人：之后又喝了7两白酒
Others: Then had about 350 grams of white liquor.
其他人：然后人就急了
Others: And then they started to panic.
Lucia: 这不加还不知道撞成啥样了
Lucia: If we hadn't added that, who knows what would have happened.
Jake:啥呀
Jake: What?
Shure: 我们能用一次性餐具
Shure: We can use disposable tableware.
Jake:不环保
Jake: Not eco-friendly.
Katrina: 那上次那个杯子打碎了
Katrina: But we broke a cup last time.
Katrina: 明天客人更多了
Katrina: There will be more guests tomorrow.
Katrina: 够用吗
Katrina: Do we have enough?
Jake:那就买几个杯子
Jake: Then just buy a few more cups.
Tasha: 买几个杯子
Tasha: Buy a few more cups.
Tasha: 不还有一次性杯子吗
Tasha: Don't we still have disposable cups?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Shure: 就是不符合我们的理念你懂吗
Shure: But it goes against our principles, you know?
Katrina: 好买
Katrina: Okay, buy them.
Jack: 严格把握ICECAR 6的要求
Jack: Strictly adhere to ICECAR 6's requirements.
Tasha: 搁那上楼
Tasha: Put it upstairs.
Lucia: icidnap
Lucia: icidnap.
Jack: 坏了符合ICECAR 6可能要被干死
Jack: If it violates ICECAR 6, we might be in big trouble.
Jake:为啥呀
Jake: Why?
Jack: 我们的数据是在强迫的情况下
Jack: Because our data was obtained under pressure.
Jake:到大晚上
Jake: Late at night.
Shure: 比如说你们boss我
Shure: For example, you guys bossing me around.
Jack: 哎他去买杯子了
Jack: Hey, he's gone to buy cups.
Jake:这边的水
Jake: This water here.
Jack: 我已经开了一瓶
Jack: I've already opened a bottle.
其他人：买汇源呗
Others: Just buy Huiyuan.
Lucia: 好晕啊
Lucia: I'm so dizzy.
Jack: 干嘛你在干嘛
Jack: What are you doing?
Jack: 他好像不能往上推吧
Jack: He can't push it up, right?
Jake:他怎么往下推
Jake: How is he pushing it down?
Jack: 呵呵他按说也不应该能往下推
Jack: Haha, he shouldn't be able to push it down either.
Lucia: 对按说他应该是固定的
Lucia: Yeah, it should be fixed.
Lucia: 为了防止
Lucia: To prevent...
Lucia: 哈哈为了防止
Lucia: Haha, to prevent...
Lucia: 那个就是从这坡上冲下去的时间
Lucia: ...from rushing down the slope.
Jack: 他有点逆天
Jack: It's a bit unbelievable.
Jake:他并不固定
Jake: It's not fixed.
Jake:我们再试试啊呵呵呵
Jake: Let's try again, haha.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia: 不是后面也有人啊但是
Lucia: But there are people behind too, but
Lucia: take care
Lucia: Take care
Lucia: so unreal now i heard this voice
Lucia: So unreal, now I heard this voice
Jake:泡椒蓝莓
Jake: Pickled blueberries
Jack: 蓝莓
Jack: Blueberries
Lucia: 啊我申请买一个蓝莓
Lucia: Ah, I want to buy one blueberry
Jack: 9块9 有点害怕
Jack: 9.9 yuan, a bit scary
Jack: 9块99块9的蓝莓
Jack: 9.99 yuan blueberries
Lucia: 应该只是其中其中一种
Lucia: It's probably just one type
Lucia: 这种好像是9块9
Lucia: This one seems to be 9.9
Lucia: 他在促销
Lucia: It's on sale
Lucia: 然后还有其他的对
Lucia: And there are other types too
Lucia: 所以大家选哪种
Lucia: So which one do you guys choose?
Jake:这个是多少
Jake: How much is this one?
Lucia: 佳沃200 这是250克
Lucia: Jawo 200, this is 250 grams
Lucia: 那可能是这个吧
Lucia: So it might be this one
Lucia: 19块9 对
Lucia: 19.9 yuan, right
Lucia: 这个会大一些
Lucia: This one is a bit bigger
Lucia: 这新加坡也19
Lucia: This is also 19 in Singapore
Lucia: 这能打开吗
Lucia: Can this be opened?
Jake:这怎么吃啊这个
Jake: How do you eat this?
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This one
Shure: 这是三室的这
Shure: This is the three-room one
Shure: 个就啊四个
Shure: Then there are four
Jake:这多少钱
Jake: How much is this?
Choiszt: 你要买要熟一点
Choiszt: You need to buy the ripe one
Choiszt: 谢冰竹放
Choiszt: Thanks Bingzhu
Tasha: 我感觉这个这边不太好
Tasha: I feel this side is not good
Shure: 怼脸拍我
Shure: Shoot me up close
Jake:就是这些东西
Jake: It's just these things
Jake:我觉得随便买到这我觉得不划算
Jake: I feel it's not worth buying them here
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Lucia: 为什么这个在新加坡很便宜吗
Lucia: Why is it cheap in Singapore?
Jake:感觉是吧
Jake: Seems like it
Jake:这个的话新加坡也是19块钱
Jake: This one is also 19 yuan in Singapore
Jake:这个的话可能
Jake: This one might be
Jack: 新加坡19块九
Jack: 19.9 yuan in Singapore
Jack: 19块9新还19块9人民币
Jack: 19.9 yuan, still 19.9 yuan RMB
Jake:19块9新
Jake: 19.9 yuan Singapore dollars
Lucia: 19块9新
Lucia: 19.9 yuan, new
Jack: 19块9新
Jack: 19.9 yuan, new
Lucia: 19块9新这么点吗
Lucia: Is 19.9 yuan this little?
Lucia: 不会吧
Lucia: No way
Lucia: 这么多是
Lucia: Is this much?
Lucia: 是organic蓝莓吗
Lucia: Is it organic blueberries?
Lucia: OK我就说这不会吧
Lucia: OK, I thought no way
Lucia: 差那么远
Lucia: That's so far off
Lucia: 那再来一盒吧
Lucia: Let's get another box
Lucia: 哦已经拿了是吧
Lucia: Oh, you already got it?
Jake:我也试不出来这些东西
Jake: I can't tell these things
Lucia: 一般来说没事
Lucia: Usually it's fine
Lucia: 对我也尝不出来
Lucia: Yeah, I can't tell either
Jake:结算就是5倍
Jake: The total is five times
Lucia: 行您真的有吓到我
Lucia: Wow, you really scared me
Lucia: 没想到啊
Lucia: Didn't expect that
Lucia: 我以为是在新加坡的价格
Lucia: I thought it was the price in Singapore
Lucia: 折成人民币也是9块9呢
Lucia: Converted to RMB, it's 9.9 yuan
Jake:西瓜西瓜要吗
Jake: Watermelon, watermelon, want some?
Nicous: 把这个当作一口币给他藏
Nicous: Hide this as a token for him
Choiszt: 这是按盒卖的
Choiszt: It's sold by the box
Lucia: 而且还能吃
Lucia: And you can eat it
Lucia: 特别实用
Lucia: Very practical
Jake:我都不记得表上写的什么
Jake: I don't even remember what the form says
Jake:回头找所有人对一对
Jake: Later, we'll check with everyone
Jake:我们p人就不管这些事了
Jake: We P people don't handle these things
Jake:你是j还是p啊
Jake: Are you J or P?
Jack: 忘了j吧忘了
Jack: Forgot J, just forget it
Jake:忘了可还行
Jake: How can you forget that?
Jake:看来这个p
Jake: Looks like this P
Jake:看来这个踢
Jake: Looks like this T
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: j人可能会记得
Lucia: J people might remember
Jack: 真的吗
Jack: Really?
Lucia: 不知道哈哈
Lucia: Don't know, haha
Jack: 我好像我好像是变过
Jack: I think I might have changed
Jack: 我是变过
Jack: I have changed
Jack: 就是e反正
Jack: Anyway, it's E
Jack: p和ent j反正
Jack: P and ENT, J anyway
Lucia: what你是ent
Lucia: What, you're ENT?
Tasha: 啊好累啊
Tasha: Ah, I'm so tired.
Lucia: 加1
Lucia: Same here.
Jake:扎着手了
Jake: Got a prick on my hand.
Jake:对对我以为很深呢
Jake: Yeah, I thought it went in deep.
Jack: 我记得
Jack: I remember...
Jack: 我记得小时候非常喜欢干这个事
Jack: I remember loving to do this as a kid.
Jack: 小孩还喜欢吃冰糖
Jack: Kids also love eating rock candy.
Jake:真是悄悄吃一个
Jake: Secretly having one.
Jake:吃个枣吃个冰糖
Jake: Eating a date, eating some rock candy.
Lucia: 那我吃了万一他们把我抓起来的话
Lucia: What if they catch me after I eat it?
Lucia: 你可要把我保释出来啊
Lucia: You gotta bail me out.
Jake:这个你你这是有
Jake: Well, you...you have...
Jake:迷彩色的
Jake: Camouflage ones.
Jake:就是你看不出来
Jake: So you can't really see them.
Lucia: 什么有迷彩色
Lucia: What do you mean camouflage?
Jake:跟这个颜色是差不多的哦
Jake: They match this color.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jack: 他这冰糖不错可以吃一把
Jack: This rock candy is good, you can grab a handful.
Lucia: 不行先吃枣吧
Lucia: No, let's have dates first.
Lucia: 要不然话就不甜了
Lucia: Otherwise, it won't be sweet.
Jake:品一品为什么有这么多种枣
Jake: Try it, why are there so many kinds of dates?
Jake:这个好吃
Jake: This is tasty.
Jack: 他比小枣好吃
Jack: Better than the small ones.
Jack: 但不知道他这
Jack: But I don't know...
Jack: 这个我感觉这个价钱
Jack: I feel like the price...
Jack: 哇这个又大又好
Jack: Wow, this one is big and good.
Shure: 咱今天晚上吃啥
Shure: What are we having for dinner?
Shure: 今天晚上
Shure: Tonight.
Shure: 咱今天晚上
Shure: For dinner tonight.
Shure: 外卖吧
Shure: How about takeout?
Lucia: 外卖吧
Lucia: Let's get takeout.
Choiszt: 再来一顿烧烤
Choiszt: Let's have barbecue again.
Shure: 麦当劳
Shure: McDonald's.
Jake:麦当劳吧
Jake: McDonald's then.
Jake:烧烤你得吃啊
Jake: You gotta eat barbecue.
Jake:今天得一点
Jake: Gotta have some today.
Jake:吃吧
Jake: Let's eat.
Choiszt: 昨天昨天
Choiszt: Yesterday, yesterday...
Choiszt: 就这个
Choiszt: Just this...
Shure: 现在才4.08
Shure: It's only 4:08 now.
Jake:我这还有事没空
Jake: I have something to do, no time.
Lucia: 那我们冰箱里那两块牛排怎么办啊
Lucia: What about the two steaks in the fridge?
Shure: 把牛排煎了
Shure: Cook the steaks.
Choiszt: 然后切了
Choiszt: And then slice them.
Lucia: 谢谢大哥
Lucia: Thanks, bro.
Jake:主厨您还需要什么啊
Jake: Chef, do you need anything else?
Jake:好谢谢
Jake: Okay, thanks.
Jack: 我们俩晚饭已经吃过了
Jack: We've already had dinner.
Jack: 建议你们自己安排
Jack: Suggest you make your own plans.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Sigh.
Lucia: 那我也尝一下
Lucia: Then I'll try it too.
Lucia: 好谢谢
Lucia: Okay, thanks.
Nicous: 谢谢你这是什么面
Nicous: Thank you, what kind of noodles are these?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jack: 是哪个嗯
Jack: What kind of "hmm"?
Jack: 谢谢
Jack: Thanks.
Jack: 非常好吃啊
Jack: Really delicious.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 我们要买几包方便面吗
Lucia: Should we buy some packs of instant noodles?
Jake:今晚吃泡面吧
Jake: Let's have instant noodles tonight.
Jack: 真的好好吃啊
Jack: It's really tasty.
Lucia: 对作为方便面来说味还可以
Lucia: Yeah, for instant noodles, it's pretty good.
Jack: 肯定是作为方便面吧
Jack: Of course, it's instant noodles.
Jack: 他们不能跟正常比
Jack: You can't compare it to real food.
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Right, right.
Jack: 方便面里面的骚塔
Jack: The best among instant noodles.
Shure: 骚塔都来了吗
Shure: The best, really?
Jack: 对骚塔呀
Jack: Yeah, the best.
Jack: 绝对骚塔
Jack: Absolutely.
Shure: 搞那么好吃
Shure: Made it so good.
Jack: 好给你们摇来了我们的金主
Jack: Alright, we've brought in our sponsor.
Jake:今晚吃方便面吧
Jake: Let's have instant noodles tonight.
Choiszt: 不如麦当劳
Choiszt: How about McDonald's instead?
Choiszt: 牛排方便面
Choiszt: Steak instant noodles.
Lucia: 牛排方便面
Lucia: Steak instant noodles.
Lucia: 我天方便面
Lucia: Oh my, instant noodles.
Jake:牛排方便面怎么样
Jake: How about steak instant noodles?
Choiszt: 不如麦当劳
Choiszt: How about McDonald's?
Jake:主厨说要吃麦当劳
Jake: The chef says McDonald's.
Jake:主厨决定要吃麦当劳
Jake: The head chef decided to eat McDonald's.
Jake:我们的主厨我们的主厨决定吃麦当劳
Jake: Our head chef, our head chef decided to eat McDonald's.
Jake:对他也吃麦当劳
Jake: Yeah, he also eats McDonald's.
Nicous: 是谁提的麦当劳啊
Nicous: Who suggested McDonald's?
Lucia: 你吧啊
Lucia: Wasn't it you?
Tasha: 麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Jake:对就是他
Jake: Yeah, it was him.
Jake:昨天一直在唱麦当劳汉堡
Jake: He was singing about McDonald's burgers all day yesterday.
Jake:然后告诉我一晚上150
Jake: Then he told me it was 150 a night.
Jake:哈哈哈建立了一些不可磨灭的联系
Jake: Hahaha, he made some unforgettable connections.
Jack: 这个真好吃
Jack: This is really delicious.
Jack: 回去回去
Jack: Let's go back.
Jack: 要买一个放我宿舍
Jack: I need to buy one and keep it in my dorm.
Jake:那你现在买
Jake: Then buy it now.
Jack: 现在买我还得拎回去
Jack: If I buy it now, I have to carry it back.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 怎么我们这么大一群人
Tasha: How come we, such a big group,
Tasha: 一辆购物车都没有呢
Tasha: don't even have one shopping cart?
Tasha: 要买一瓶鲜牛奶
Tasha: We need to buy a bottle of fresh milk.
Jack: 曾经我们是不是有一辆购物车
Jack: Didn't we used to have a shopping cart?
Lucia: 曾经我们有一辆购物车
Lucia: We used to have a shopping cart.
Jake:你的车是不是大了
Jake: Is your car too big?
Jack: 我们现在只剩一辆
Jack: Now we only have one left.
Jake:车丢了我们车丢了
Jake: The cart is missing, our cart is missing.
Jack: 他好像丢了
Jack: It seems like it's lost.
Jack: 有东西这个出来
Jack: Something came out of it.
Jack: 健康的ipad在里面
Jack: The healthy iPad is inside.
Jack: 哈哈哈丢了个iPad
Jack: Hahaha, we lost an iPad.
Jack: 我操
Jack: Damn.
Lucia: 哦等等
Lucia: Oh, wait.
Lucia: 那我的那个啥是不是也在里面
Lucia: Then isn't my thing also inside?
Lucia: 有道理
Lucia: Makes sense.
Lucia: 我充电宝和那个和那个线
Lucia: My power bank and that cable.
Lucia: 不行我们得去找那辆车去
Lucia: No, we have to find that cart.
Jack: 我操
Jack: Damn.
Lucia: 不行我充电宝和线还在里面呢
Lucia: No, my power bank and cable are still inside.
Jack: 没事你没他
Jack: It's okay, you don't have his stuff.
Jack: 你没他的东西值钱
Jack: Your stuff isn't as valuable as his.
Lucia: 不是吧那根线好像很值钱的样子
Lucia: No way, that cable seems pretty valuable.
Lucia: 哈哈我不知道啊
Lucia: Haha, I don't know.
Lucia: 就是对吧
Lucia: Exactly, right?
Lucia: 在哪啊
Lucia: Where is it?
Jack: 我们刚刚从那边过来都没走那边
Jack: We just came from over there, we didn't go that way.
Lucia: 要不掉我们来
Lucia: How about we go over there?
Jake:我们来复盘
Jake: Let's review what happened.
Lucia: 你现在能把这个视频数据调出来
Lucia: Can you pull up the video data now?
Lucia: 看一眼吗
Lucia: Take a look?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:你找找我从这开始出来
Jake: Try to find when I start from here.
Lucia: 会不会在楼下呀
Lucia: Could it be downstairs?
Lucia: 但这好像下不去了
Lucia: But it seems like we can't go down.
Lucia: 推上来的OK
Lucia: Pushing it up is okay.
Jack: 这个吧这个这个
Jack: This one, this one, this one.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 幸好
Lucia: Luckily.
Lucia: 呃您好
Lucia: Uh, hello.
Lucia: 请问这个是现称吗
Lucia: Excuse me, is this for weighing?
Lucia: 楼下收银台称OK
Lucia: The downstairs cashier weighs it, okay.
Lucia: 嗯找着了
Lucia: Hmm, found it.
Shure: 这是啥呀
Shure: What is this?
Lucia: 西梅
Lucia: Prunes.
Shure: 是吃的吗
Shure: Are they for eating?
Lucia: 是啊不是不是吃是要称的
Lucia: Yeah, no, not for eating, they need to be weighed.
Lucia: 哈哈哈是是
Lucia: Hahaha yes, yes.
Jake:李子
Jake: Plums.
Lucia: 西梅我挺爱吃这个
Lucia: Prunes, I quite like eating these.
Lucia: 他说楼下称
Lucia: He said to weigh them downstairs.
Lucia: 我刚问了
Lucia: I just asked.
Lucia: 哎呦咱咱这平均下来一人才吃俩
Lucia: Oh no, if we average it out, each person only gets two.
Lucia: 不会拉肚子的
Lucia: We won't get an upset stomach.
Jake:对啊怕丢了
Jake: Yeah, afraid we'll lose them.
Lucia: 这是to do list吗这是
Lucia: Is this the to-do list?
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh my.
Jake:我看看有多少自由发挥的
Jake: Let me see how much is improvised.
Choiszt: 我们两盒不太够吃
Choiszt: Our two boxes aren't enough to eat.
Jake:哈哈哈这个是也挺自由啊
Jake: Hahaha, this is also quite freeform.
Jake:还有吗
Jake: Is there more?
Jake:哦那这些是干嘛的
Jake: Oh, what are these for?
Shure: 这些
Shure: These?
Shure: 这也是给嘉宾
Shure: These are also for the guests.
Shure: 就是哎
Shure: It's just, hey
Jake:行行行
Jake: Alright, alright, alright
Shure: 怕嘉宾们吃
Shure: Afraid the guests might eat
Jake:因为怕嘉宾们吃不惯
Jake: Because we're afraid the guests might not be used to it
Shure: 因为中国有句古话叫有朋自远方来
Shure: Because there's an old Chinese saying, "When a friend comes from afar..."
Jake:你有几个朋友
Jake: How many friends do you have?
Lucia: 你有几个朋友
Lucia: How many friends do you have?
Lucia: 虽远必诛
Lucia: "Though far away, must be punished"
Lucia: 可还行有朋自远方来
Lucia: How about that, "When a friend comes from afar..."
Lucia: 虽远必诛
Lucia: "Though far away, must be punished"
Lucia: 哈哈哈这是一种新新的弱智吧吗哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha, is this a new kind of stupidity? Haha
Nicous: 哈你竟然没看过阿巴斯
Nicous: Ha, you haven't watched Abbas?
Lucia: 没有不知道
Lucia: No, I don't know
Jake:抖音吗
Jake: TikTok?
Jake:阿巴斯
Jake: Abbas
Nicous: 点开最近的一个
Nicous: Click on the latest one
Jake:印度歌
Jake: Indian song
Nicous: 你看评论区
Nicous: Look at the comment section
Jake:阿巴斯你知道吗
Jake: Do you know Abbas?
Lucia: 我也要看看
Lucia: I want to see too
Jake:但丁真去过地狱
Jake: Dante really went to hell
Lucia: 神经病
Lucia: Crazy
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Lucia: 如果你来我家的话
Lucia: If you come to my house
Lucia: 我会请你吃槟榔羹
Lucia: I'll treat you to betel nut soup
Jake:为什么这阿巴斯是什么沙雕
Jake: Why is Abbas such an idiot?
Katrina: 是外国人
Katrina: He's a foreigner
Katrina: 大家都在他评论区里说一些中文
Katrina: Everyone is saying something in Chinese in his comment section
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
露Nicous: 你觉得现在是一锅粥了
Nicous: Do you think it's a mess now?
Lucia: 趁热喝
Lucia: Drink it while it's hot
Jake:他在学中文是吧
Jake: He's learning Chinese, right?
Nicous: 嗯
Nicous: Yeah
Nicous: 对
Nicous: Yes
Nicous: 阿帕斯你什么时候来北京
Nicous: Abbas, when are you coming to Beijing?
Nicous: 我骑着你去爬长城
Nicous: I'll ride with you to climb the Great Wall
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Nicous: 阿巴斯你
Nicous: Abbas, you
Nicous: 记住是金子总会发光
Nicous: Remember, gold will always shine
Nicous: 但但是你是老铁
Nicous: But you're a true friend
Lucia: 哈哈哈但是你是老铁
Lucia: Hahaha, but you're my buddy.
Jake:你是老铁
Jake: You're my buddy.
Lucia: great
Lucia: Great.
Jake:行行行看着不错
Jake: Alright, looks good.
Jack: 金刚已经麻了
Jack: King Kong is already numb.
Jake:这超市也看见不错
Jake: This supermarket looks good too.
Lucia: 哈哈哈这超市
Lucia: Hahaha, this supermarket.
Jack: 京爷特有的看起来不错
Jack: Jingye's special looks good.
Lucia: 嗯sorry
Lucia: Hmm, sorry.
Lucia: 哎从这下
Lucia: Hey, get off here.
Lucia: 他定不住是吧
Lucia: He can't stay still, right?
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
Jake:你不是j人吗
Jake: Aren't you a J person?
Jake:那你的菠萝哪来了
Jake: Then where did your pineapple come from?
Choiszt: 在我计划之内
Choiszt: It was part of my plan.
Jack: 本就在计划之内
Jack: It was always part of the plan.
Jake:本就在计划啊
Jake: It was always part of the plan, huh?
Jake:我在琢磨这是个p
Jake: I was thinking this was a P.
Jake:车这是个j车
Jake: This car is a J car.
Jake:结果好像并不是这样
Jake: But it doesn't seem that way.
Lucia: p社
Lucia: P club.
Jake:p车
Jake: P car.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Jake:p车和j车
Jake: P car and J car.
Jake:j车上面还挺通俗的
Jake: The J car is pretty common.
Jake:p车还没啥东西
Jake: The P car doesn't have much.
Jake:就是丢了
Jake: It's just lost.
Lucia: 丢了很p确实
Lucia: It's really lost, indeed.
Choiszt: 啊他在等那个拉面
Choiszt: Ah, he's waiting for the ramen.
Jake:哦他想
Jake: Oh, he wants
Jake:吃拉面
Jake: to eat ramen.
Jake:那他知道我们下来了吗
Jake: Does he know we're downstairs?
Jack: 不一定
Jack: Not necessarily.
Jake:那我们上去吧
Jake: Then let's go up.
Choiszt: 葡萄汁白砂糖桂花
Choiszt: Grape juice, white sugar, osmanthus.
Jack: 刘帅对这还有研究嘞
Jack: Choiszt even researches this stuff.
Choiszt: 看一眼
Choiszt: Just a glance.
Choiszt: 这不是正在促销
Choiszt: Isn't this on sale?
Lucia: RIO
Lucia: RIO.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Jack: 这是香槟吗
Jack: Is this champagne?
Choiszt: 对
Choiszt: Yes.
Jack: 香槟还有这么便宜的
Jack: There's such cheap champagne?
Choiszt: 这个XO为什么就89块钱
Choiszt: Why is this XO only 89 yuan?
Jack: 不知道啊
Jack: No idea.
Katrina: 这个称了吗
Katrina: Did you weigh this?
Choiszt: 嗯到时候一楼称
Choiszt: Yeah, we'll weigh it on the first floor.
Jack: 一楼称
Jack: On the first floor.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Jack: 这个一楼称吗
Jack: Weigh it on the first floor?
Lucia: 他说结账的地方称
Lucia: He said weigh it at the checkout.
Jack: OK
Jack: OK.
Choiszt: 这两瓶嗯
Choiszt: These two bottles, hmm.
Katrina: 还是他是做甜点
Katrina: Or maybe he’s making dessert.
Choiszt: 好
Choiszt: Okay.
Jack: 两瓶两个车形成鲜明的对比
Jack: Two bottles, two cars, such a contrast.
Choiszt: 我觉得这个这么多东西
Choiszt: I think this is so much stuff.
Choiszt: 三个人三个人
Choiszt: Three people, three people.
Jack: 那建议你速速找健康要方里
Jack: Then I suggest you quickly find a health prescription.
Nicous: 这是买给嘉宾吃的吗
Nicous: Is this for the guests to eat?
Nicous: 不可能这个东西可可危害健康了
Nicous: No way, this stuff could harm health.
Nicous: 吃瓜子会上火
Nicous: Eating sunflower seeds causes heatiness.
Nicous: 油炸食品
Nicous: Fried food.
Katrina: 话筒怎么解决来着
Katrina: How to fix the microphone?
Katrina: 都不能吃
Katrina: None of this can be eaten.
Nicous: 我们晚上一起吃就可以了
Nicous: We can eat it together at night.
Jack: 咸鸭蛋配汉堡
Jack: Salted duck egg with burger.
Shure: 中西结合
Shure: Fusion of East and West.
Nicous: 好这一口
Nicous: This bite is good.
Nicous: 想太久
Nicous: Thinking too much.
Jack: 我好奇就是你是北京人
Jack: I’m curious, you’re from Beijing.
Jack: 你能喝豆汁吗
Jack: Can you drink douzhi?
Choiszt: 不喝
Choiszt: No, I don’t.
Choiszt: 我都没怎么吃过那个北京小吃啥的
Choiszt: I barely eat Beijing snacks.
Jack: 真的吗你从小到大都没吃过
Jack: Really, you never had it growing up?
Choiszt: 没咋吃那个都是人家老北京
Choiszt: Not really, that’s for old Beijingers.
Tasha: 经过我们严密严惩的计算
Tasha: After our careful calculations.
Jake:加餐了
Jake: We added more food.
Choiszt: 哎这小瓶他买了点大
Choiszt: Hey, this small bottle he bought is kinda big.
Jake:对就是这个
Jake: Yeah, that's the one.
Jake:稍微便宜
Jake: A bit cheaper.
Jake:便宜个一毛半
Jake: Cheaper by 0.15 yuan.
Choiszt: 一毛半行不行啊
Choiszt: Is 0.15 yuan okay?
Tasha: 这一毛半的微信
Tasha: This 0.15 yuan on WeChat.
Choiszt: 为了这一毛半
Choiszt: For this 0.15 yuan.
Choiszt: 然后再就然后买了好多
Choiszt: And then I bought a lot.
Tasha: 抠抠搜搜
Tasha: So stingy.
Tasha: 花了很多
Tasha: Spent a lot.
Nicous: 不是
Nicous: No.
Choiszt: 这个和这个放在一起我有点于心不忍
Choiszt: Putting this together with that makes me feel a bit guilty.
Tasha: 为什么
Tasha: Why?
Choiszt: 那搁那车里哈
Choiszt: If we put it in the car.
Shure: 都是matter
Shure: It all matters.
Shure: 不是吗
Shure: Right?
Shure: 是不是咱们开发票
Shure: Aren't we invoicing?
Shure: 开什么演出
Shure: What kind of show?
Shure: 有限公司
Shure: Limited company.
Jack: 我们只能开感觉时间
Jack: We can only invoice for a certain time.
Jack: 有限公司
Jack: Limited company.
Shure: 我们我们开发票的话应该
Shure: If we invoice, we should.
Katrina: 走吧
Katrina: Let's go.
Katrina: 前面结
Katrina: Settle it up front.
Shure: 但是国外报销他走发票的
Shure: But abroad, they reimburse with invoices.
Jake:都不走
Jake: They don't.
Lucia: 都不走发票啊
Lucia: They don't use invoices?
Lucia: 国内一般都有
Lucia: Usually, they do domestically.
Jake:走走预算报账
Jake: They go by budget reimbursement.
Lucia: 说到这个既然快递都到的差不多了
Lucia: Speaking of which, since almost all the deliveries have arrived.
Lucia: 可以报销一下吗
Lucia: Can we get reimbursed?
Lucia: 好的我怎么发呀那就
Lucia: Okay, how should I send it?
Jack: 好
Jack: Sure.
Lucia: 那我怎么发呀
Lucia: How should I send it?
Lucia: 难道截图发你吗
Lucia: Should I screenshot it to you?
Jake:我我回头弄Excel
Jake: I'll do it in Excel later.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Tasha: 我要弄吗
Tasha: Should I do it?
Tasha: 呃都大家都要弄Excel是吗
Tasha: Uh, should everyone do it in Excel?
Jake:对啊
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 他他弄一个然后共享我咱们贴就行
Shure: He'll do one, then share it, and we'll just paste it.
Lucia: 哦好的
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Lucia: 哦sorry哈哈哈
Lucia: Oh, sorry, hahaha.
其他人：我操
Others: Damn.
Lucia: 哦这里有这个
Lucia: Oh, there's this here.
Lucia: 这这个茶很好喝
Lucia: This tea is really good.
Lucia: 嗯这个茶很好喝
Lucia: Mmm, this tea is really good.
Jake:哈哈哈可能下个月让你懂一懂
Jake: Hahaha, maybe next month you'll understand.
Lucia: 我们要不要来一盒
Lucia: Should we get a box?
Lucia: 请嘉宾喝
Lucia: To serve to the guests.
Lucia: 还是算了319 哈哈哈
Lucia: Or maybe not, it's 319, hahaha.
Lucia: 但是他们家茶真的很好
Lucia: But their tea is really good.
Lucia: 这应该是一个北京的老字号好像
Lucia: This should be an old Beijing brand, I think.
Shure: 这谁的线掉了
Shure: Whose wire fell off?
Lucia: 他再多待几天
Lucia: He stays a few more days.
Lucia: 回新加坡的时候就该乘5了
Lucia: When he goes back to Singapore, it'll be times five.
Lucia: 是我的是我的
Lucia: It's mine, it's mine.
Lucia: 生命线
Lucia: Lifeline.
Lucia: OK OK
Lucia: OK, OK.
Lucia: 我给眼镜续个命哈
Lucia: I'll give the glasses a new life.
Lucia: 他现在没灭吧
Lucia: They're not dead yet, right?
Jake:没灭
Jake: Not dead.
Lucia: 那就行
Lucia: Then it's fine.
Lucia: 83特别满
Lucia: 83 is really full.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 哎这里面还有一个充电宝
Lucia: Hey, there's a power bank inside.
Lucia: 啊好的
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Jake:你要不也插上生命线
Jake: Why don't you connect your lifeline too?
Tasha: 哎那个人招手让我们过去呢
Tasha: Hey, that person is waving us over.
Shure: 啊好好哦
Shure: Oh, okay.
Lucia: 那边有那个啥
Lucia: There's something over there.
Lucia: 要插吗我帮你找地方扔
Lucia: Want to connect? I'll help you find a place to throw it.
Lucia: 一会再插
Lucia: We'll connect it later.
Jake:他一直不给我就是他自己扔
Jake: He never gives it to me, he just throws it himself.
Tasha: 哈哈哎呀我不好意思让你通了
Tasha: Haha, oh, I'm sorry for letting you through.
Lucia: 问问问一下那个
Lucia: Ask, ask, ask that person.
Lucia: 没看着我没找着哒
Lucia: Didn't see it, couldn't find it.
Lucia: 吓死了
Lucia: Scared me to death.
Lucia: 我刚还以为这根线找不到了呢
Lucia: I just thought I couldn't find this wire.
Tasha: 找不到了要赔多少钱
Tasha: If you can't find it, how much do you have to pay?
Jake:不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Lucia: 没有考虑过这种问题
Lucia: Never thought about that.
Jake:这一些很难想的问题我们就不想
Jake: Let's not think about these difficult questions.
Lucia: 什么
Lucia: What?
Lucia: 袋子
Lucia: A bag.
Lucia: 能装下吧
Lucia: It should fit, right?
Lucia: 啊对不起
Lucia: Oh, sorry.
Choiszt: 没事感觉有点浅这个袋
Choiszt: It's fine, but this bag feels a bit shallow.
Lucia: 可以先放重的
Lucia: We can put the heavy stuff in first.
Katrina: 送我一个洗衣凝珠
Katrina: Give me a laundry pod.
Lucia: 洗衣凝珠
Lucia: A laundry pod?
Katrina: 需要开发票吗
Katrina: Do you need a receipt?
Jake:需要开发票
Jake: Yes, we need a receipt.
Lucia: 这能不能放下呀
Lucia: Can this fit?
Katrina: 嗯这边这么多才400
Katrina: Hmm, all this for just 400.
Katrina: 再拿一个不
Katrina: Want to get another one?
Lucia: 再拿一个
Lucia: Let's get another one.
Lucia: 这个玻璃杯好危险啊
Lucia: This glass cup is really dangerous.
Choiszt: 还没出超市就碎了啊
Choiszt: It broke before we even left the supermarket.
Jake:已经碎了
Jake: It's already broken.
Lucia: 啊没有没有
Lucia: Oh no, no it isn't.
Choiszt: 碎了也不能换了
Choiszt: Even if it's broken, we can't return it.
Choiszt: 这个这么搁真的没问题吗
Choiszt: Are you sure this is okay like this?
Katrina: 拿着吧反正就几个袋子
Katrina: Just hold it, we have a few bags anyway.
Katrina: 这么多人来拿
Katrina: There are so many people to help.
Lucia: 哎呦喂
Lucia: Oh dear.
Lucia: 拿着
Lucia: Hold it.
Lucia: 防止他那个啥
Lucia: So it doesn't...
Lucia: 呃我们都装好了OK
Lucia: Uh, we packed everything, okay.
Lucia: 哔哩哔哩干杯
Lucia: Cheers, Bilibili!
Lucia: 虽然这个语序完全错乱
Lucia: Although the word order is completely messed up,
Lucia: 但好像能看懂呢
Lucia: It seems understandable.
Lucia: 语序完全错乱
Lucia: The word order is completely messed up.
Lucia: 什么杯子
Lucia: What cup?
Shure: 不是这两个能拿
Shure: No, these two can be taken.
Shure: OK车就不用拿了
Shure: Okay, no need to take the cart.
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Be careful.
Jake:好拜拜
Jake: Alright, bye.
Jake:关了吧嗯哎
Jake: Turn it off, yeah.
Jake:上车就关
Jake: Turn it off once we're in the car.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:上车关好
Jake: Turn it off in the car.
Tasha: still hour for
Lucia: 看中文中文语序打乱并不影响阅读
Lucia: Reading Chinese with scrambled order doesn't affect comprehension.
Lucia: 大概能看懂是什么意思吧
Lucia: You can roughly understand the meaning, right?
Jake:满一二8元
Jake: Spend 128 yuan.
Lucia: 哦满一二8元
Lucia: Oh, spend 128 yuan.
Lucia: 一分钱购物洗衣凝珠
Lucia: And you get laundry pods for a penny.
Lucia: 我说我刚刚这样看了半天
Lucia: I was looking at it for a while just now.
Lucia: 不是他送了一个
Lucia: Didn't he give one for free?
Jake:他是购物首付满821
Jake: It's a promotion where you spend 821.
Lucia: 满821满128吧应该满
Lucia: Spend 821, spend 128, right?
Tasha: 他从这边开始看
Tasha: He starts looking from this side.
Jake:那128是吧
Jake: So it's 128, right?
Tasha: 我为什么那买两个也128
Tasha: Why did I buy two and it's still 128?
Lucia: 哎有道理
Lucia: Oh, makes sense.
Lucia: 但反正他当时确实给咱送了一盒
Lucia: But anyway, he did give us a box.
Lucia: 洗衣凝珠
Lucia: Of laundry pods.
Tasha: 应该送两盒
Tasha: Should have given two boxes.
Lucia: 对我们应该结完128就停顿然后
Lucia: Yeah, we should stop after spending 128 and then...
Lucia: 你看这个就是从左往右阅读
Lucia: See, this is reading from left to right.
Tasha: 在多点会员上面免费买
Tasha: You can buy for free with more points.
Tasha: 150元就可以免费
Tasha: 150 yuan and it's free.
Jake:他字体为什么能做成这样
Jake: Why is the font like this?
Lucia: 我也想问问
Lucia: I want to ask too.
Jake:他为了省纸
Jake: To save paper.
Lucia: 那那个满字为什么那么大
Lucia: Then why is the "spend" character so big?
Jake:满可能省不了
Jake: Maybe can't save on that.
Lucia: 我怎么还有点晕
Lucia: I'm feeling a bit dizzy.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Tasha: 假的
Tasha: Fake.
Lucia: 这这是毛的吧
Lucia: Is this fur?
Lucia: 他们那穿不上吧哎
Lucia: They can't wear this, right?
Lucia: 不是不是是是那普通的夏天的衣服
Lucia: No, no, it's regular summer clothes.
Lucia: 没摸出来
Lucia: Can't tell by touch.
Lucia: 但应该不是棉
Lucia: But it's probably not cotton.
Lucia: 不像纯棉
Lucia: Doesn't feel like pure cotton.
Jack: 看着就不像纯棉
Jack: Doesn't look like pure cotton.
Lucia: 小猪猪
Lucia: Little piggy.
Lucia: 出现
Lucia: Appear.
Lucia: 消失
Lucia: Disappear.
Jake:总之就是算个总账拿个清单
Jake: Anyway, just tally it up and get a list.
Jack: 哎那你周二从从北京回哪
Jack: Hey, where are you heading from Beijing on Tuesday?
Jack: 新加坡上海
Jack: Singapore or Shanghai.
Jake:没想到没想到这层
Jake: Didn't expect that, didn't see that coming.
Jack: 先先过完明天
Jack: Let's get through tomorrow first.
Jake:哈哈哈后天再想这一层
Jake: Haha, let's think about it the day after tomorrow then.
Lucia: 没事他可以到了机场
Lucia: It's fine, he can decide at the airport.
Lucia: 然后随机选择一个目的地
Lucia: And then just choose a destination randomly.
Jake:先到机场
Jake: Just get to the airport first.
Jack: 指定的是给航空公司捐钱
Jack: Yeah, it's like donating money to the airline.
Jack: 你当天晚上
Jack: On the same night.
Jake:我省钱
Jake: I'm saving money.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 你错过了很精彩的故事
Lucia: You missed a really exciting story.
Jake:对不赶不上飞机
Jake: Right, missing the flight.
Jake:然后要退票或者不给退的话也很麻烦
Jake: And then having to refund the ticket, or if they don't refund, it's a hassle.
Jake:所以就比较浪费钱
Jake: So it's kind of a waste of money.
Jack: 那你为什么不提前买好呢
Jack: Then why don't you buy it in advance?
Jake:就是提前买好
Jake: I do buy it in advance.
Jack: 你提前买好一个你能赶上
Jack: If you buy it in advance, you can make it.
Jake:那很难哈哈哈
Jake: That's really hard, haha.
Jack: 这有点抽象
Jack: This is a bit abstract.
Lucia: 你看所有人听到都觉得不可思议
Lucia: Look, everyone finds it unbelievable.
Jack: 我操这有点抽象啊
Jack: Damn, this is a bit abstract.
Jack: 啊我靠这那很难受
Jack: Ah, damn, that's really tough.
Jack: 没想到
Jack: Didn't expect that.
Tasha: 他永远提前买好赶不上车
Tasha: He always buys in advance and misses the train.
Tasha: 这是很让人感觉很奇怪的事情
Tasha: It's really a strange thing.
Lucia: 我在欧洲坐火车
Lucia: When I take trains in Europe.
Tasha: 去电影院哎
Tasha: Going to the cinema.
Tasha: 下一场最近的时候是什么时候啊
Tasha: When's the next showtime?
Tasha: 然后就直接买下一场了
Tasha: Then I just buy the next one.
Lucia: 这个我也会
Lucia: I do that too.
Lucia: 不过我每我去电影院
Lucia: But whenever I go to the cinema.
Lucia: 每次都是先到那再看看哪一场
Lucia: I always check the showtimes first.
Lucia: 要不然我赶不到
Lucia: Otherwise, I can't make it.
Lucia: 我只要提前买电影票
Lucia: Whenever I buy movie tickets in advance.
Lucia: 就无论我提前多久
Lucia: No matter how early I buy them.
Lucia: 我最后都会错过片头
Lucia: I always miss the beginning.
Lucia: 哈哈哈是不是也很匪夷所思
Lucia: Haha, isn't that bizarre too?
Lucia: 啊这个好
Lucia: Ah, this is good.
Lucia: 谢谢谢谢
Lucia: Thank you, thank you.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 今天这也不是很远
Lucia: It's not that far today.
Lucia: 但我竟然真的有点晕车
Lucia: But I actually feel a little car sick.
Lucia: 这个座还能往后那个啥吗
Lucia: Can this seat go back any further?
Lucia: 就这样吧
Lucia: Just like this then.
Lucia: 金彩城亲子广场
Lucia: Jincai City Family Plaza.
Lucia: 啊上车是不是要关这个
Lucia: Oh, should I close this when getting in the car?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 他经常会提示我minor data quality issues detected
Lucia: It often reminds me of minor data quality issues detected.
Lucia: 好了
Lucia: Alright
Lucia: 不会再转了
Lucia: It won't spin anymore
Lucia: 没有他说咖啡店
Lucia: He didn't say anything about a coffee shop
Lucia: 我现在真的有点PTSD
Lucia: I'm really feeling a bit of PTSD right now
Lucia: 检查一下
Lucia: Let's check it out
Jake:他这边有这个修
Jake: He has this repair thing here
Jake:叫什么回收旧的电器
Jake: What's it called, recycling old appliances
Tasha: 为什么要喊他
Tasha: Why are you calling him?
Jake:因为他明天把琴带过来了
Jake: Because he's bringing the instrument over tomorrow
Lucia: 啊他说他
Lucia: Oh, he said he...
Lucia: 然后我们说他怎么拿回去
Lucia: And then we asked how he's taking it back
Lucia: 他说当二手直接在这卖了
Lucia: He said he's selling it as a second-hand item right here
Lucia: 谁啊哈哈哈哈sorry
Lucia: Who? Hahaha sorry
Lucia: 哈哈对不起我现在真的有点PTS
Lucia: Haha sorry, I'm really feeling a bit of PTSD right now
Lucia: 因为那个好近然后
Lucia: Because it's so close and...
Jake:但是一般恶犬
Jake: But usually, fierce dogs...
Lucia: 内有恶犬
Lucia: Beware of the dog
Lucia: 对那个小狗只是个无心之师哈哈
Lucia: Yeah, that puppy is just a harmless teacher, haha
Lucia: 33
Jake:密码多少啊
Jake: What's the password?
Nicous: 但是但是
Nicous: But, but...
Lucia: 要我帮你拿一个吗
Lucia: Do you want me to get one for you?
Jake:还可以你要不拿这个
Jake: It's fine, why don't you take this one
Lucia: 都行都行
Lucia: Either way, it's fine
Jake:那咱拆一个
Jake: Then we'll open one
Lucia: 那我拆了
Lucia: I'll open it then
Lucia: 哈哈哈可以可以
Lucia: Hahaha okay, okay
Lucia: 盛情难却
Lucia: Hard to refuse such kindness
Tasha: 我们三个人的瓜分史还少吗
Tasha: Haven't we divided up enough stuff already?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahaha
Jake:芒果还剩一个
Jake: There's one mango left
Lucia: 芒果还剩一个
Lucia: There's one mango left
Lucia: 都不够咱仨瓜分的
Lucia: It's not enough for the three of us to share
Lucia: 哎你今天转化的那个呢
Lucia: Hey, what about the one you processed today?
Jake:那没称因为我全给转化了
Jake: Didn't weigh it because I processed it all
Lucia: 转化到肚子里了是吗
Lucia: Processed into your stomach, huh?
Jake:全被我转化了
Jake: I processed it all
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Alright
Lucia: 好像没有
Lucia: Seems like there's none left
Lucia: 也没看着
Lucia: I didn't see it either.
Lucia: 百利甜也没看着
Lucia: Didn't see the Bailey's either.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 看成定投了
Lucia: I misread it as SIP.
Lucia: 对不起看成了定投
Lucia: Sorry, I misread it as SIP.
Lucia: 定投定投
Lucia: SIP, SIP.
Lucia: 就是一个金融术语
Lucia: It's a financial term.
Jake:好吧定投我懂了
Jake: Okay, I got it, SIP.
Lucia: 哈哈哈打扰了
Lucia: Hahaha, sorry for the interruption.
Alice:有没有觉得非常干净哦
Alice: Don't you think it's super clean now?
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow.
Tasha: 不认识这个家了
Tasha: I don't recognize this place anymore.
Lucia: 谢谢可心好干净
Lucia: Thanks, Kexin. It's so clean.
Alice:但是一摆又又凌乱了
Alice: But once we start placing things, it'll get messy again.
Lucia: 这次我们尽量维护
Lucia: This time, we'll try to maintain it.
Lucia: 特别有区别
Lucia: It's really different.
Lucia: 请请请您吃
Lucia: Please, please have some.
Lucia: 这个已经打开了啊那
Lucia: This one's already opened, so...
Lucia: 喝喝喝来来来杯茶
Lucia: Drink, drink, have a cup of tea.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Alice:现在只有剩刷的东西没有弄好
Alice: Now there's only the brushing left to finish up.
Alice:还有楼上的桌子什么也擦了
Alice: And upstairs, the tables are wiped too.
Alice:然后也只剩刷了
Alice: So, just the brushing left.
Jake:我们开摄像头
Jake: Let's turn on the camera.
其他人：开摄像头
Others: Turn on the camera.
Jake:大家先休息一下
Jake: Everyone, take a break first.
Jake:不要工作
Jake: Don't work.
Choiszt: 这个去哪了啊
Choiszt: Where did this go?
Jake:这个不要了
Jake: We don't need this.
Jake:这个放后面
Jake: Put this at the back.
Tasha: 那这个眼镜就关掉了
Tasha: Then I'll turn off these glasses.
Jake:呃关关
Jake: Uh, turn them off.
Jake:倒一闭
Jake: Close it.
其他人：一会一会
Others: In a bit, in a bit.
其他人：一会搞好了帮我看看我那个
Others: Once it's done, help me look at mine.
Katrina: 打火机
Katrina: Lighter.
Choiszt: 那你头像分辨率多少
Choiszt: What's the resolution of your profile picture?